so let's
dive right into the introduction of
damian
damian is working for ibm he has
various different roles as a background
he's been a consultant an architect and
a developer
and nowadays from ibm he's fully
dedicated
to promoting development and also open
source
and the example you'll be giving is
about building a corona radar and i was
just discussing with him when you were
all
coming in that he has had some really
interesting presentations he joined
a panel at tweakers and i hope
you have a great experience with him
walking
you through the end-to-end project of
how to build such a corona radar
yourself so please get ready to do some
code yourself
you'll be presenting for an hour and we
hope to get you
interactive during the order itself and
afterwards we have an
hour of aftercare where you can ask
questions and you can continue doing the
code
so without any further ado
let's give the floor to damian
right so if uh things work here then you
should
at least have a look at my git page
right now which is
all hosting all the files on gitlab so
that should work i'll
first thing i'll do i'll share the link
with you so you can have a look yourself
and maybe even go along but
what i plan to do in this first hour is
mainly
walking you through all the code there
and
getting to know what's what's available
uh the link is also in the in the
discord channel so you should be able to
find that
um and um yeah i'm going to
walk you through and talk you through uh
through the code that i've
made available there if you go one
folder up there's a lot of
there's lots more because i i spent the
last six months on doing these kind of
analysis so there's there's a lot of
experiments there as well
and a lot of other stuff you uh you
might explore but yeah beware that this
uh
pi data folder is is more or less
documented
and the rest is typically uh not
documented lots of experience and
probably stuff that's broken and won't
work so uh
so yeah if you keep to this folder you
you should be fine
um right so uh yeah what happened uh
i've
been working in data science as they
call it now i still don't really like
the term but uh
well data mining and machine learning
and whatever you want to call it
uh for the last 25 years so i'm a
computer engineer by
by origin i studied artificial
intelligence after that uh when
people were just starting to think about
artificial intelligence and uh
and and see seeing it as a as a
potential job to be honest i mean the
thinking about artificial intelligence
uh probably started just after the
uh during the war with alan turing but
uh and
and maybe even before uh so yeah and at
that time it was mostly a philosophy
thinking about
what we could do building very very
small neural networks uh
consisting of two nodes and and layer
perhaps
uh so that's that's what we were doing
uh lots of knowledge based systems rules
based systems and and stuff so uh
yeah basically i joined ibm after that
and i've always been working in that
area so um so what happened
um yeah early this year uh yeah
obviously this this
pandemic broke out uh cases were really
starting to rise in china we were
wondering what was going to happen
um ibm when uh the when it when it
arrived in europe and the us
ibm sent us all home to work from our
home office luckily i have a good home
office so that
that helps a lot and uh so and at the
same time that was
well uh late late march early april um i
was
wondering about new material for
workshops this year because that's my
current job at ibm i'm
what's called a developer advocate so i
i do these kind of workshops for people
trying to inspire them to work with this
kind of technology
and then hopefully obviously because i
work at ibm and
maybe use some ibm technology there as
well today what you will see is is all
open source it's
all based on freely available libraries
and and all the code that you see is
also freely available
as should be clear because it's it's all
available on my git
pages um so uh so yeah i was wondering
about the new material for workshops
my wife who is a nurse uh was uh
starting to get very busy at our local
hospital
in full isolation daily treating
suspected covit patients at the time
so i was really wondering what can i do
what can i contribute to this
this course so can i i as a data
scientist have a look at this kind of
data and and
find interesting stuff that people can
use to mitigate the impact of
of this this whole outbreak so that that
is where it started
so first thing was first thing was
just looking for data so at the time
there was not that much available so i
found the eocdc website
which i can show you here and um that's
uh at that time that was one of the few
places where they had a daily update of
case data
and in this case worldwide um because
obviously i wanted to say something
about the dutch uh situation
i would really like to to help out here
more or less
uh and and as a side project uh
uh for for getting interesting workshop
material
um so but but then i thought yeah i want
to
understand the nature of disease
outbreaks and how does that work and how
can you
model that or can you say anything about
it
uh in prediction or projection of
progress of a disease outbreak
so then then i thought yeah what i have
to do and what you should do as a data
scientist is not just look at the dutch
situation because then you get a picture
and maybe a totally overfitted picture
of the dutch situation
where you can easily build a model that
fits the dutch
outbreak perfectly but it doesn't
generalize
most of the time so yeah thinking about
overfitting i thought yeah i need to go
and have a look at as many outbreaks as
i can because if you can find some
similarities between outbreaks in uh
south korea and finland and iceland and
and south america
uh brazil uh for example uh then
uh yeah if there's if there's similarity
there's then there's probably
that's some kind of ground truth then
you can generalize
over those outbreaks so i started off
with that
data set um and uh yeah
what so what i do now and what i still
do daily is just download this
this data set which is available as an
excel file and
also as a csv file at the time the csv
file was pretty unstable to be honest i
had
all kinds of problems where suddenly all
columns were there were no commas
anymore
and stuff wasn't quoted probably
properly or suddenly quoted and then the
day after
it wasn't so i got used to using the
excel file which is available there
luckily in xlsx format um
but now i can probably switch back to
the csv file it wouldn't be such a
problem so uh
if you want to use the csv file it's
also available there
there's the link here where you can
download it and you would be able easily
to
change change the code that i i i've
available for you
to use the csv file because yeah excel
files can be tricky i
you've probably seen this one just in
the news where lots of
uh uk cases weren't reported properly
and they blame excel but yeah they
should probably blame themselves
because what they did is they used the
old xls format
not the xlsx format where you can only
have
uh 65 536 rows
in an excel sheet so um
so that uh that yeah
so they uploaded from csv files locally
into that excel format
and then uh yeah lots of rows got lost
so
lots of people weren't paying attention
and i don't think it's really
uh you you shouldn't blame excel i guess
in this case but
using csv files is always is always safe
then on the other hand the xlsx format
that they use here can do a million rows
so
for now that's enough because in this
data set
uh every row is uh is a date
uh so for each date you get for each
country uh the the current figures
so we're not yet that extended into the
into the pandemic that we already have a
million dates away
available so we should be fine uh
although we all also
uh thought we should be fine in the year
2000
uh in the years before that so never
assume
but for now i guess the the excel uh the
excel format
would be safe um yeah so we have what i
did i i just fired up a notebook and
then you have to know that
most of the the experience that i have
uh as the data scientist until uh well
basically until april was in other
environments than
than python and juvederm notebooks so
for me it was also a learning experience
so
i've got quite some experience in data
science and analysis i used
just about any tool you can imagine i
guess starting out with a sequel and
and doing uh even rex scripts and
and whatever whatever you and at the
time uh lots of
programming in in c and and whatever
because before
python was generally available and used
as a
as a data science language most of the
time so yeah i did use python
these these past couple of years but not
really in depth and and not not
not good enough i i thought for myself
so i also thought yeah let's dive in and
see
how to use python for this this kind of
stuff and i think that is the right way
uh i guess for uh for approaching
something like this
uh people who want to be a data
scientist tell me yeah i want to be a
data scientist so i'm first going to do
a python course and then and then we'll
see what we get
um i always turn it around and i say no
don't learn python
start on an on a project and learn the
python that you need for
doing the project and for getting to to
success and then properly your python
codes won't uh won't be that nice
and and i and i hope you can comment on
that today and tell me that i can do
stuff better but i just used it as a
tool i just said okay i want to
get more insights into the outbreak of a
disease
uh find out what's going on and i'm
going to use python for that so that's
and and and learn it on the way so um
yeah i made all these notebooks more or
less standalone i try to at least so
you should be able to get them into any
environment that you use
be that bare bones uh jupiter notebooks
or
youtube lab which i started using some
time ago
or or anaconda or or whatever cloud
environment that runs
jupiter notebooks they try to at least
download their own data and if needed
they install their
their own uh prerequisites so uh yeah
what i started doing is just
at the top of this notebook i just
started using wget to
to get these files in there's there's
also python libraries for that i know
but
this is clean and easy so at the top of
the notebook i always download the
current data
and i check with minus n here to see if
there's new data available
and download it if necessary so that's
where i started
um yeah and then there's there's one
thing so i i talked to you about
not trying not to overfit on the local
situations by
you using very many different
many different countries and outbreaks
and the second thing was
i also always at the start of my project
try to use as little data as possible
and that may sound strange
and then i don't mean the length of the
data set so as many days as i get can
get
but as little columns as you as you can
use
because i always say first start with
the facts and and start with the data
that you have for every country
i could have started looking at for
example infection rates or
hospitalizations
figures or stuff like that but certainly
at the time and still
that was not available for all the
countries so if you start building a
model and you want to use
hospitalization rates in this case um
yeah you can only use the countries
where you have that data for and then
automatically you get a bias for that
kind of countries
because well typically let's say that
you only have hospitalization rates for
uh for western european countries for
example
then you can only build your model on
that and you get a model that is
probably over fit for western european
for western europe and you can't use it
in any case to
to say something about other countries
so minimal data set
in this case i started using uh
basically only the dates
uh which are a little bit aggregated in
this data set so you
uh so you use three columns to uh to uh
to start with uh and you can do that
from any data set
it's it's it's that flexible i hope so
what you need is a date
a location and a number so the data set
typically tells you on this date for
this location which are countries in
this case
i have this number for newly for
newly tested positive cases in this in
this
notebook so yeah that's a matter of
importing the notebook getting it into
pandas running into all kinds of nice
stuff that you always run into when you
start using data in practice
like a country which is called namibia
which has a g-o-i-d-n-a
and you can imagine what happens when
you try to import that into pandas which
sees a column that's called which has
data that's uh that's called n
a which is available but but coded is
not available so
there's always that kind of stuff so it
took took me a while to
to get this imported in the right way uh
running some checks but i'm i'm not
going to
to fully run through this whole notebook
you can you can do that yourself
basically
so uh so in the in the second hour pick
it up run it and
and tell me what uh tell me what's going
on there um
so yeah then there's the the the matter
of uh of
a uh of getting the data into the right
shape for for analysis
uh i always say get yourself into an
environment where you can start asking
questions as quickly as possible
uh so in this case what i did is i
pivoted the data
uh into a into a data frame which is
much easier for for querying and
comparing stuff
so i did what i did here from this data
set because there's case and disease
data available
i basically created two big slices cases
and depths which are the values in this
in this pivot statement
i uh i said let let each row be a date
so date becomes an index here
uh which is also great for plotting as
we will see uh later on
uh so the date becomes the becomes the
index becomes the
the row uh index and uh the countries
become columns so that's basically what
this this
statement does here um yeah which was
pretty easy
uh it was pretty easy until i found out
that i had not available columns here
and stuff like that which
pandas really doesn't like and which
turned out to be namibia but
there you go once once you have the data
uh corrected you uh you can get this
nice uh you can get this nice pivot
table out of your
out of your data and we will see later
on that there's lots of other
possibilities of solving this obviously
but
at that time i just said okay let's do
it this way um and then you see a lot of
not available inside the columns but
that's that's easy because
i mean the country andorra which is here
a d uh did not report anything for this
date so there's uh there's not available
there
um afghanistan for example did report
for that date but they reported zero
cases
so that's already something that you
have to keep in mind
that you could treat the not available
here
probably mostly as as being zero cases
for that day
but then again there could be suddenly
some not available uh
popping up uh in in a time series uh
while there's lots of cases being
reported and suddenly you get not
available
then there's probably something else
going on there so pay attention to these
to these values which which you will
obviously see when you start
visualizing uh so you had some
description of the columns here
i always put a transpose after my
describe here that you get nice a better
overview of what you're
what you're doing here uh yeah and then
to the first drafts and yeah then
pandas makes that pretty easy uh you can
obviously use matplotlib directly
uh but that's that's a lot of statements
usually so it it's pretty easy
if you have your data in the right
format like i did where you can simply
start
firing off statements like this or you
just say okay from my data frame i want
the cases for the netherlands and just
plot it for me
and then if your if your index is is uh
your index is by default taken as the
x-axis so you yeah it's pretty easy to
start drawing plots here
so first thing was just to reproduce the
the curves and the graphs that you saw
all over the place so yeah that makes it
pretty easy if you simply
do a us here then you get the plot for
us it's that easy so you can start
asking questions and looking at your
data
uh first thing that you see here is
there is a very clear
weekly reporting pattern here
so yeah we solved more or less or at
least we looked at
the data problems uh then the next thing
that you encounter when you start
looking at your data obviously
is the reporting process that produce
this data
so you also have to find out what's
going on there so i was wondering here
and looking at data and it's for just
about every country
you see that tuesdays are peak days and
when you read up on that you find out
that most of the cases for the weekend
are usually reported on tuesdays so that
means that you already have to
do some smoothing on the data to get to
get to the right results
because you have very naively if you
just run a time series on this
which i did and especially at the rising
stage
yeah then everything that you get out of
that will be just
a simple prediction where uh where the
time series tells you uh
okay next tuesday will be higher than
the other days because that's usual on
tuesdays
and it will also be higher than last
tuesday because that was going on on
that at that
time so you really need to do to do some
some more data engineering some more
future engineering to uh to really find
out
what's going on in a country like this
because your time series if you if you
just run it here
it will never predict this this kind of
graph i mean that would just not happen
so uh there's quite a quite some of your
own intelligence that you have to put in
here to uh to find out what's going on
so you have to scroll uh downwards a
little bit so there's quite some stuff
here you can look at uh
obviously if you want to look at other
stuff you can
look at deaths here as well instead of
instead of
uh cases so if you just select the death
data you see a totally different pattern
and you see that the weekly reporting
pattern in
in disease data is even stronger so you
have to take that into account
so a lot of examples here so have a look
through it you see
weird reporting spikes in this case for
china and you can see what
what was going on there you can easily
do logarithmic plots
you can put a lot of countries inside
one graph by just
giving it a a a
a list of countries that you want to
plot here you can do logarithmic scales
so
options enough so play around have a
look and see what you can do
so you can do relative cases you could
look at the doubling rate
um but yeah back to the beginning uh
thinking of my wife working in the
hospital and thinking about the the the
loads that we are having on our
uh on our healthcare system i was
thinking yeah what what's
uh and everybody at the time was talking
about flattening the curve
uh yeah the next question then is uh
well i i can see the curve now and i can
can uh query it for lots of countries
but what is that curve and
and if you're talking about flattening
it uh what what does that mean what what
is it
why is a flattened curve different than
another one and
how does that look comparing comparing
countries so yeah then you have to think
about this curve and uh
in the beginning you saw a lot of people
trying to fit the typical bell-shaped
curve to this data
and that worked pretty well in the
rising in the rising
slope of this of this curve
but if you look at if you look at what's
going on afterwards here you see a
couple of countries uh and you see for
example corrected data for china so
have a look at how that works by taking
uh by taking a rolling
window over the data but if you look at
the curve you can see okay the rising
one is maybe uh can can be uh described
by a gauss
curve by a logistic curve but you can
always see that the the
down slope is always longer so that it's
it's a long
longer tilt distribution and uh yeah
you even saw uh specifically for uh for
the u.s
uh uh a while ago that um
uh that was in april where people said
okay if we are inside this bell-shaped
curve and the downslope looks the same
the as the upslope we will probably end
up around 60 000
deceased in for the us um yeah
obviously that didn't work that didn't
work for two reasons
uh which is what we will be looking in
at right now
uh two reasons uh one uh it's not a bell
shed curve it's not symmetrical
uh the downslope is longer than the
upslope so that's that's one thing
uh and and the second thing is there
will obviously obviously be
something happening after this first
huge wave that we saw in
lots of countries so you can already see
stuff happening
here during the summer which there are
some local some local peaks
and yeah and then most of the countries
unfortunately
are now at least for the for the number
of people tested positively
and i know there's a big discussion
there so we can have that as well but at
least for the people tested positively
you can see there's there's a steep rise
now and and there's lots of countries
who are testing
much more uh cases right now than than
they did in april and obviously
therefore finding much more positive
cases but yeah
it is on the rise and that is that is
worrying i mean even if you're testing
much more here
uh it's it's it's rising and and the
number of tests isn't rising that fast
as the graph is so
uh yeah we are we're uh we're getting
into trouble uh again or
are already into trouble uh at least in
the netherlands there's already
uh a usual healthcare that's being
scaled down
to take care of corona patients so
something's going on so the shape of
this curve and yeah
and and there's more than one so uh how
to deal with that
uh yeah then i went deeply into curve
fitting um
which is uh something that i had never
done before so i really had a look at
how does this work
and there's all kinds of curves that you
can use to try to make sense of this so
i looked at gauss obviously
first which is the symmetrical one i
used at gamma
there was people talking about gunport's
curve so i really dived into that
and then i found out that uh if you look
at this
kind of data in in a little bit
different way you're not looking at
uh the the classical infection model
where you basically look at
what is the infection rate and how high
is the chance that somebody gets
infected on a certain date so how high
is that
probability you have to do all kinds of
assumptions about the underlying model
and about
how many people meet other people and
stuff so you really have to
make a more or less a model of society
to to do that right
which is something that that quite some
countries tried i mean in in sweden they
they had this model where they
try to model just about every citizen in
a model and try to
predict what the behavior would be and
then how high the probability would be
that somebody would get infected and
stuff like that
um but obviously i mean people were
already doing that
and i was thinking can we do this
differently and then i was thinking
about a lot of work that i did for uh
that i did in
predictive maintenance uh and in
predictive maintenance what you do is uh
you don't look at the probability that a
machine
will be breaking down on a certain date
but you will mostly be looking at the
distribution
of the time to failure so you say okay
i'm going to put this machine
on the floor in the in the factory i'm
going to switch it on and i've got
a maybe a 100 of those machines and then
i can look at the distribution of the
time to failure and
and and i can i try to model that so
what i did is i tried to to model this
kind of data in the same way by saying
okay i'm
uh considering that that you if you put
a person in a society in in certain
circumstances
uh he's going to work or not or he's
working from home or his
uh he's meeting his children or not or
he's going to parties or not
uh according to the circumstances
there's a certain uh probability
uh that that there's a time to well in
this case time to of
infection so uh so i used that approach
and and not looked at the daily
probability but looked at the time to
infection and the distribution that
that fits to that then after quite some
research
and that is maybe a little bit of the
science part of data science although
although i don't consider myself a data
a scientist
people call me a data scientist but i
guess that's something else
anyway um i i ended up using this
distribution to approach the data uh
which might be
one that you've never heard before
because that was the same for me i had
never heard of a gumball distribution
but the chemical distribution usually
does is it models extreme values
so if you look at uh for example
temperatures in a country
and you gather the maximum temperature
for each year
so you have that kind of data set
showing the maximum of a underlying
probability distribution
uh and you just you
draw the distribution of those maximum
values then you get a gumball
distribution
so that is that's what i used here and
yeah i i talked to quite some people
uh who do uh uh uh have some knowledge
about epidemiology
and virology and i i considered this
useful because i said okay if you
consider the daily uh
probability of of getting infected as
your underlying
distribution and you say okay the
maximum of that is the
the amount of time that you get infected
so that's a maximum of the daily
infection probability um yeah you
i i considered that uh prove enough that
you at least could try if a comfortable
distribution would fit
and i see the remark that uh uh somebody
says okay this reminds me of vibel
uh actually uh vibel and gumball are are
variants of the same kind of
same kind of family of distributions so
yeah
it's it's it's very much related to
predictive maintenance
and then again gimbal distribution is
used all over the place so there's quite
some knowledge about uh
how that works because it's also used
for uh
predicting earthquakes uh because that
is also something uh
it's usually for for uh extreme values
uh related
stuff is also used in in risk analysis
for example
where you where you usually say okay the
uh small risks are happening uh often
uh that's what you see in the
distributions here and the large risks
are
are not that often but they they are but
they are much larger
in this case um yeah somebody says did
you try with bible too um yeah
that is the not science part of my of my
work that i uh i
i uh i i took the assumption that
gumball would work
and i just started trying it in practice
and it worked wonderfully that's
basically my answer
so that i didn't try if a bible would be
better in any case
because i could explain the usage of
gumball it worked good in practice
and and it was pretty easy
with a bit of high school mathematics to
be honest to be honest
uh to find out how i could fit this in a
proper way to the data
because the the formulas for gumball
aren't that uh aren't that complex it's
basically just
the the cumulative function of gumball
if you look at the cumulative
cases in this case is basically just a a
double exponent
i'm not sure if you can read that i'll
enlarge it just a little bit more
so the cumulative is just a double
exponent of a linear function
yeah and that made it yeah i thought
okay if i'm going to use this one
then basically what i have to do is just
take the cumulative
daily uh reported data
take the double lock of that one and
then i should have a line
so that is that is basically what i what
i did here so the the the curve fitting
uh with this kind of function can be
easily reduced to linear regression
so you take the the cumulative
distribution you just take the logarithm
twice and and
take care of the minus signs there and
then you end up with something that
should look like x minus mu divided by
beta which is a line
uh so that was my first assumption and
and then i just
tried that basically um
so i i have this notebook available
which is
i don't think i've put it in the pi data
folder we can have a look at that
which is uh this one where
it's just one one one folder up so you
should be able to find it
and and that's that's what i what i uh
explored in this
in this in this notebook so somewhere
around here you will see this function
reduced to a line
uh there you go and if you just do the
double exponent of the cumulative data
you end up with a line which is the blue
data and i just fit a line to that
and then if you have the formula for
that line you get the you have the right
parameters and you can simply double the
exponent you can do the
exponent twice again and you should get
a curve that's uh that's that was
basically the the
the the approach that i used so if you
do that for just
the the first outbreak for the
netherlands for example uh you get this
kind of
results where the blue is the is the raw
data
uh the orange one is the smooth data i i
took a weekly
efforts window over the data to take out
this these reporting
effects uh the orange one isn't that
visible but it's it's it's in there
and the green one is is my fitted uh is
my fitted curve
uh yeah i know obviously try started
doing that for for
all the countries and all the outbreaks
that i could found and could find
and while you can already see from the
linear regression here
that it fits almost perfectly so so yeah
the curve
fits this outbreak curve also in a very
very good way lots of statistics behind
that you can have a look at
how well it fits and stuff like that but
believe me uh
i tried i tried a lot and it seems to
generalize here
um yeah but then uh the problem cropped
up of of multiple
uh outbreaks because yeah you can
already see here for the netherlands
it's very nice that you can fit this
first wave and tell something about it
and and you can already fit it on the
upslope here and tell a lot about what's
going on so you could try to fit this
second one
or third one even if you look at the
data maybe there's already an outbreak
somewhere here
um so how to deal with that then i uh
really dived into into the formulas for
gumball again
uh i derived a relative measure for the
data so i said okay we're not going to
look just at the cumulative data but
we're going to look at the new cases
related to the total until then
because that's a number you can compare
across countries you get you get a kind
of relative number
and how would that work well the nice
thing was if you
if you calculate that with using the
gumball distribution
uh you get something that you can easily
reduce to a series of
a series of lines um so then i
yeah i got into trouble a little bit
because i said okay
for now i just did linear regression i
could reduce this to a line fit a fit a
line to that and calculate it back to
to this according curve but now i need
something that can detect
a lot of lines so i found this one
discussing it with with a colleague as
well which is called
multivariate adaptive regression splines
the acronym is mars as you see here
and you'll see that back in the code as
the earth library in python
because the the the algorithm isn't uh
isn't uh
trademarked uh or patented in any way
but the name is so nobody can use the
name mars because that's
that's a trademark so the the open
source implementation of mars
all over the place is called the earth
which is a bit of a joke but that's
that's why the
the earth library is in there um okay so
this one
but what this does is this is able if
you have a uh
if you have data that really consists of
a couple of lines
uh you can use mars to find out
the parameters for all these lines so
it's basically a
multiple uh multiple regression uh
model and yeah if you look at it
related to machine learning basically uh
you can consider it
as a clustering algorithm so what mars
try to do is it says okay i've got this
cluster of points here
and i'm going to cluster that into this
line piece here and i've got another
cluster of points there and i'm going to
cluster those into a second
uh linear part of the of the data
um yeah and then you get into all the
usual stuff that you have with
with clustering algorithms there's also
there's lots of other clusterings you
can imagine here too
so what it does it assumes that it's a
series of lines so you have to have data
obviously that
that fits there but then again yeah you
could you could do all kinds of
clusterings i mean you could also do
just straight linear regression here and
get
get one line for this whole data set
which then wouldn't fit that that well
um but um and and and otherwise you
could
you could for example draw a line
between every of these two points and
get
uh get as many lines as you have data
points
which is also a a feasible clustering so
what mars tries to do
uh which is parameterized and and and
you'll see that i i try to find the
right parameters for
for the for most outbreaks that i've
seen in uh all over the world
uh to get to get this right basically uh
but yeah there's still
this clustering problem where you always
say and that's also in marketing
uh i've done a lot lots of marketing uh
where you do uh where you do
persona and trying to cluster the the
clients of your
of your of your organization into
clusters uh yeah you could
consider all your clients in one big
cluster which which is a way of looking
at it but it doesn't help you very much
on the other hand you could try to cater
for every client individually
which is also uh feasible uh which is
also a a
a good clustering but that also doesn't
help you very much so you also have to
strike the balance between
putting everything in one big cluster
and uh treating every case individually
so that's that's what we're trying to do
here
uh and that yeah obviously there's
there's quite some stuff to say about
that
and that also makes the analysis in the
end sometimes a bit inconsistent
because uh yeah i dived into the earth
algorithm or the mars algorithm
to try to find out how can i
consistently fit a series of lines to
the data
that doesn't always work that well when
new data comes in so that's that's still
something to uh to
to be analyzed basically but okay i said
if you use this approach you can
probably uh get to know more about
uh about your data than just staring at
this
at this full graph so that's what i
implemented in this
worksheet which then yeah uh installs uh
its own uh
by earth uh implementation luckily uh
it's uh it's available through sklearn
so i
i call it directly here but at least
because of that you can easily install
it
so that's what this notebook does so
yeah i would basically
invite you to uh to have a look at that
yourself i will run
i will scroll a little bit through it
just to tell you what's going on
but before we do that i can tell i can
show you a typical output of it
because this is what then finally comes
out so now i've got the uk here you can
simply
uh simply fill in other countries here
and this is how it
fits the curve for the uk so what it
basically does
is it finds this big lump of data at the
beginning that can be
more or less fit into one curve you can
already see
probably if you look at it more
fine-grained you could do multiple
curves
here and it would fit even better but
then you get into
how useful is that to look at all these
individual outbreaks
so basically for the uk the the optimal
fit i would say in this case
based on the parameters that i chose
would be one big lump in the beginning
and then some smaller outbreaks so
things were going right so there were
there were other outbreaks there
but they they didn't get out of hand but
then yeah
obviously after the holidays people
came back into the country or maybe
there were
measures were released here in this
period so you can see that new outbreaks
are
are starting there so that is that is
basically what you can uh
can get from this graph so what i try to
do is
find out the underlying outbreaks just
looking one level below the whole curve
and trying to see uh what what you can
what you can get from those insights
um so how do you use this how does this
tell you anything about
uh caseload and and stuff that happens
um yeah you can see you can obviously
see changes in policy here
if people start testing more or if
people start behaving differently
or if a lockdown is introduced you can
see if that influences in any way the
way that new outbreaks
look and
and you can try to learn from it if you
if you try to make sense of these
underlying outbreaks so for example if i
look at
the netherlands you can see outbreaks
that are
starting for example one week
after mother's day one week after easter
one week after we had a long weekend
with the whitson weekend where there was
also a lot of demonstrations
so i can't say that these outbreaks are
caused by those demonstrations but at
least there's a
time relation between those and you can
see after the holidays you can see
in if you look at more detail which we
will do
after this at regions in the country you
can see that typically where students
are returning to their homes you can see
that there's uh huge outbreaks in those
in those cities even if they weren't hit
that hard
in the beginning of the year so you can
try to make sense of what happened
try to learn from that and for example
see i mean we all know that christmas
will be will be coming at the end of
december so if you look at the
uh well let's say the easter related
outbreaks in lots of countries
perhaps you can learn something about
that
um i see a couple of questions in the
discord which i'll
have a look at seasonality
yeah well seasonality is obviously
something that comes into play
when you look at it over years i would
say
you can see a clear difference between
northern hemisphere countries and
southern hemisphere countries in the
in the way that the outbreak outbreaks
proceed there
so i'm not going to say that that is
caused by seasonality
uh but because it could also be caused
by simply
that those countries typically take
other measures or behave differently
uh but yeah um you could you could try
to say something about
seasonality by by analyzing these uh
these graphs i would say
and the underlying outbreaks um so um
let's see this
uh
yeah well so yeah indeed there's there's
lots more to say about this i mean i'm
i'm just
uh i'm just scratching at the surface of
what you could
try to do with this kind of analysis so
she's notice
is typically a a big part of this um
then this question which if i would be
fit uh able to fit all the outbreaks
with different linear regressions
created by mars that is yeah that is
basically i would i would i i can't say
uh yes to that easily because i
i don't know if i caught all the
outbreaks uh but yeah i get
good figures in in my overall fit let's
say
of the underlying outbreaks that i
detect uh if i relate
them to the full to the full number for
those days
and in these graphs the blue background
is the actual is the actual data
the pink one is my model which should
then
very well overlapped the blue one
basically um and
uh yeah there's there's a difference
obviously and you can see the effect
here at the end
of the data um that there's a big spike
here
that can either mean that there's a lot
of cases now breaking out here um
but i know for the united kingdom that
based on this excel glitch that we just
looked at that they've
that they didn't report uh the cases for
last week in the last couple of weeks
fully so now they suddenly report all
those cases
in in a couple of days so probably this
spike is just a data spike
but it could also mean that that cases
are very much on the rise i mean
there's not enough data here to
statistically reliable fit another curve
to this one
but usually what i see when you see this
kind of outbreak or this kind of
effect in in a country uh that in in the
following days there will be a new uh
wave fitted to that and that that could
be a huge one uh
i think we have some i have some
examples for local data
uh where you can see that uh where you
can see that happening
um yeah there's there's a question about
any way to quantify you increase
in testing just for it yes there is
there is a way
obviously you can can look at the
testing figures for countries
which are more and more available now in
the beginning i didn't have that at all
i couldn't
even see how many tests there were so
the only hard data i had was
positively positively tested cases
you could also say yeah the the deceased
figures are more reliable
but even there there's there's a big
assumption in the deceased figures
i mean what is a corona death that that
is a definition that you can
that you can discuss for days and and
lots of countries have a different
definition of what uh what a corona
death is
for example in belgium they say okay if
somebody
is suspected of corona and then dies and
we didn't even test him we count him as
the corona death
so they have a huge death figure uh
which is not because that
is actually more people are dying there
because of corona but because they
measure it in a different way
so that's that's always a problem at
least i assume that over the outbreak
here that testing
circumstances were more or less constant
and what i've seen happening is that
when a
country suddenly starts more testing you
get
by the clustering algorithm the data
becomes separated into two ways because
then it says okay i've got this this
outbreak that was running under the
first testing circumstances then
circumstances changed
so there will be another outbreak a
separate outbreak
and that means a separate uh linear part
in the in the in the in the reduced
graph
uh for the new circumstances so then uh
that is the way you usually see
uh that testing uh changed a lot uh in
this case i know that it did
uh because we are testing much more the
uk is testing much more
uh so there will be uh and and and uh
it's different people that get infected
now so it's much more younger people
uh so the percentage of people that
actually ends up in hospital is also
much lower so yeah there's quite some
stuff you have to take into account in
in interpreting this kind of data but at
least
so i'm not saying this tells you the
truth i'm more
more saying this gives you a one extra
layer of information
for research that's that's basically
what i what i try to do here
so i'm also not saying i'm predicting
here
and i would also say
because because i i cannot predict a
next wave
uh basically i cannot predict that
people are suddenly going to have lots
of illegal parties
next weekend um but uh i can tell them
i can i can at least try to fit the
current situation
and say okay if nothing changes then we
will be
this this wave will progress in this way
because that's what i
usually see happening so it's also uh
yeah one of the basic problems you also
have
always have in trying to say something
about
the future in these kind of cases um
because this is this is probably not
going to happen because
circumstances will change and other
people are looking at these graphs are
well
as well and eventually what you're
looking at here is
behavior of people and that will change
over time and they will react to this
kind of news as well
so a couple of weeks ago or already
longer
there were there was this news article
about
students returning to their universities
in alabama
and there were 30 000 students going
back to university
and within a week they had over 500
infected
so at that moment when they're when they
were just starting to get into into this
new outbreak
i could fit a huge curve to that which
would contain
150 000 people
but i would almost say luckily that
didn't happen because they had already
were starting to take measures they were
going into lockdown they were closing
bars they were
very strict on social distancing on the
campus
so that that wave never happened luckily
i would say
so in the days afterwards this thing
became lower and lower and finally ended
up as a way for
about 15 000 people uh yeah then you can
say on the one hand yeah your model is
crap because it predicted
ten times as much and it didn't happen
at all uh but yeah
that is how it works and that that has
also always been
my frustration in all kinds of risk and
and fraud
related projects um that as a data
scientist you're doing your best
uh to make your prediction not true
uh because you're saying okay i'm i'm
predicting a lot of fraud
being going to happen in the next month
for this kind of
uh law or this kind of regulation
uh and then you tell uh the government
that you suspect that that's going to
happen and then they take measures and
the fraud never happens or or is a lot
less um yeah and then people tell you
yeah your model was crap because it
predicted all this fraud and it didn't
happen no
it's the other way around that that is
what the model was for to prevent that
from happening
so that's always something yeah that's a
daily practice that you always have to
take into account in
models like this right
yeah i see the question would it make
sense to use different curves base on
whether or not there's a lock down in
the country at the time yeah i i try to
turn that around and say okay i'm not
going to do any assumptions about that
i'm just going to
draw my curves and from there trying to
find out if
things were differently so for example
can i find a difference in
people returning from holiday in
different countries so there will be a
larger or smaller wave in in all those
countries
um and is that related to them having a
lockdown or having current time measures
or whatever so it's
basically the other way around i try to
use it as a
as a trigger to start investigating that
kind of stuff so um
actually there is a couple of notebooks
as well available
not not in the pi data folder that look
at measures related to
severity of outbreaks so uh i i also did
that kind of analysis but uh yeah
we got we can't do it all uh in in this
morning so
okay right so what happens i'll just
just scroll through it a little bit
to when you're later on looking at it so
at the top
um it's just does the basic thing it
imports his own data looks if there's a
new
new data available it does the
well-known pivot there
so that's that's just about the same as
in the other one
then i what i do is i extend my data
frame by one year so i have room in the
data frame for
for projected values so that's that's
what's what's going on with this
in this case here so you can see it gets
extended to
uh october 7 20 2021 uh
because the data for today is not in yet
it usually gets available uh somewhere
between uh
12 and 1 pm uh so it's yesterday's data
you can see here some checks here
i define the gumball functions here
which are just straight from
from the wiki page and then you just uh
uh get into here um so i
it is a bit documented but uh it can
always be better
so what i do is here i i create a slice
of data where i can uh can
start putting my my wave data into so i
i
where i try to detect waves uh i look at
the minimum number of cases i found out
that for large countries if you try to
fit to
every day 10 15 20 people being
positively tested
that is mostly noise for the model so i
usually look at
one in a million cases for for the
population for that country
and luckily there is a population count
in the in the data set that i use
and i say but but it needs to be at
least two if i always look at one case
or zero cases you get all kinds of
spurious fits
so i i found out that looking at at
least two cases per day is
is it usually works let's put it let's
put it that way but it's a parameter you
you can you can change that around so
basically what i do is
i create this curve i create this
relative measure here
uh by saying uh i take the measure
divided by the cumulative sum of the
measures until then so this is
something that you should be able to
recognize then i say that this number
should be larger than zero
because there's sometimes negative
numbers of cases reported
there's all kinds of stuff in in the
data
i take off a little bit of noise at the
beginning and the end of the graph here
for uh for fitting
then i basically uh take these two
columns which is a day number
and a number in my data set that should
be linear and i fit an earth model to
that so here i call the earth model
there's some quite some parameters here
that you can change around to find lots
of little lines or a couple of large
ones
that's basically what you would like to
see in your output so you can say okay i
want
only only three curves at maximum fitted
and you then you will have a general fit
which
uh has a lot of error or you can say i
want lots of multiple
small curves so that's basically the
parameterization of of the earth call
here
um yeah and then there's just a lot of
stuff in in trying to
make sense of the output of earth so i i
detect the line
i i detected the knots which as they are
called
which break the curve into separate
lines
and i uh detect the the most suitable
line piece at that time to fit a curve
to
that's what's happening here so here's
the selection algorithm there's also
lots to it
that you can say about that so i try to
find one which doesn't contain two
little days so if i have a line that
only contains two days for example
you can have a perfect line between two
days but it doesn't tell you very much
so there's stuff in there like like that
here i break out if i don't have any
data left
and basically what's going on here is
that i find out
the slope and the intercept of that line
so i just look at the figures and and
try to find out what that
what that line that would look like and
i calculate
for the gumball distribution my beta and
my mu parameters
from the slope and the intercept which
is basically a bit of uh
i would say high school equation solving
where you can say
uh how do i calculate those so if you're
interested
have a look at the wiki for gumball and
then i just apply that
and i say okay if i found this bit i
knew for the gumball distribution
i have to scale that back to the
original data because the distribution
is always between zero and one so i
scale that back to the original amount
of data
that's the the final number that i get
which is the final number of people
in in that wave uh yeah and then i just
calculate that back into the data frame
so i just apply this this function to
the to my
uh to the day numbers in my data frame
and get a uh get a
wave out of that then what i do is
i fitted that part of the data so i
subtract that
from the original data and then run the
whole thing again to find
the next suitable linear piece to
fit a curve too so basically the whole
thing is then just an iteration
uh in in doing that and this is the text
output so you can have a look at
what that gives you so it tells you the
the according that mu values uh
i i i do derive some kind of fit measure
uh still
lots of discussion about that how that
how you should uh
how you could do that because there's
lots of ways you can do a measure but at
least you can compare them so
there's a couple of curves that don't
fit that well as others at least you can
see here
um yeah and if you have the data you can
see okay when did it start
when was the first case in this in this
uh wave
uh oh sorry that's the the front figure
here uh when when was the
when is the peak so when is there the
highest load for the
for the for the country uh for this wave
uh when does it end and how many people
are contained in this wave so basically
the output of the clustering algorithm
uh assigned 220 000 people for the uk
to this first wave that's what it what
it tells you here
so that's the output here and yeah and
then basically the based on this this
data
uh i just do the plot so uh there's
there's just basically a uh
a list of curves that i build up while
running this iteration
and i just plot them all with a couple
of uh parameters here
um and and there you go then you get to
get this this kind of plot
um so i have a look at it yourself or
yeah uh or or let's let's discuss in the
in the in the coming hour
yeah to finish off um i i talked to a
lot of people about that and they said
yeah we need more local data so that
that is that is useful obviously you can
look at
more more local data so for the
netherlands i found this data set
which is daily published published by
the rivm
in the netherlands which is the the
dutch health institute
um and they have a daily case file that
they
publish where every line is a case and
they even tell you something about
about that case like age and gender and
stuff like that
so uh basically this uh this notebook is
is much similar to the to the previous
one
uh it picks up the the case data for uh
for local areas in the netherlands
and it does the this this is what it
looks like so one case per row in this
case so we have to aggregate this to
daily data
which is something you can easily do
it's just a different pivot statement
that's that's being used here so
there's there's some stuff in here in
getting the data into the right format
here you can say okay i'm going to use
as a region i'm going to use a kind of
column here
you can even do the experiment of for
example using age group as region
so you get different curves drawn by age
group so
there you can easily change that so if
you simply put age group here in
in the region variable it will analyze
on that
analyze on that column
so here i do the pivot which looks a
little bit different here because
there's
uh because i have to aggregate as well
so i assume the data for a date so
there's an
aggregation function in there as well i
say okay
let's let's put a zero for every missing
value in there that's that stuff that's
uh that's going on there
so then basically i get the same format
as i had before uh and i get the
uh for each each date for each uh region
in the netherlands
uh i get the figure that i'm going to
use in my in my analysis
yeah and it's basically the same code
the only thing that i did is i just put
a big loop around it i said for region
in regions so i do this for every region
that i find in data
i i i go through the whole procedure and
create this graph so basically this is
the same stuff going on here and there's
now a big loop around it so
for uh every region in the netherlands
it will calculate this uh
these figures uh and it will output a
graph for each of these regions
so there you go this is for example uh
the southern south
south holland uh it's out of london even
so that's
that's the southern uh southwestern part
of the netherlands
uh where you get these regional uh uh
outbreaks so yeah you can you can
start seeing differences between these
these regions so this is amsterdam for
example
where there was a huge uh amount of new
tested cases let's let's put it that way
so
and it's luckily it's already going down
but you can see that probably
in one of the next days there will be
there will be a new wave
probably be fitted here let's hope it's
lower than the previous one
uh but yeah you can you can have a look
through this this this stuff and see
what
what's going on uh you can see even
within a region sometimes
clear regional effects so for example
this is a part of the netherlands where
they did not have one big outbreak
but it was basically a couple of smaller
regions inside that region that
went after each other i i actually did
the research and found found
out that this actually represents what
happened there
uh so yeah and you can see that yeah all
this talking about second waves um
for this region i i already say they're
already in their 16th
wave so yeah if that's usual useful for
your decision maker
uh uh discuss it with uh with uh with
him or her
uh and if they say yeah we've we can't
do anything with 16 waves that it needs
to be less you can change the
earth parameters and and try to get a
different fit yeah and then the last
one because this whole stuff was about
building a corona
radar so in the last five minutes i'll
invite you to to try this out for
yourself
what i basically did if you have this
data for regions and you have this
fitted
this fitted data uh yeah you could you
could put it on a map i mean these are
regions in the country so why not put it
in a map
so i used folium for that i'm not sure
if you if you
have seen volume before but it's i've
used it before very useful library for
mapping data
uh it uses uh map data from
openstreetmap and you can simply give it
a list of coordinates and values and it
will
plot it for you so for a static map
that's pretty easy uh i found out
there's also an animated
plugin for for volume uh it's called
heat map with time uh there's there's
some documentation in the in the read me
about that
um yeah and hitman with time needs a
special very specific input format so
the the most
uh i spent most of my time getting the
data into the right
shape for outputting it on the map um
so what it does it i created it it
reached the output of this previous
notebook i did something that i
didn't tell you but at the very end uh
it outputs all these predicted
projected data for all these regions in
a in an output file
in a csv file in this case and this next
notebook picks up that csv file
and and gets it into the right format
for uh for plotting
um yeah i created for every region these
latitude longitude
uh coordinates uh they were not
available for these regions so uh
that was just an hour of uh looking at
google maps and finding out the right
latitude and longitudes but okay
that's that's just work you have to put
into it uh luckily for us
states for example uh you can get a list
of that
um yeah and then there's just quite some
some manipulation so what i obviously do
is i tie
these this output data from my previous
notebook which
again has three columns it has a date it
has location
and a projected value i tied this to the
to the latitude longitude values
i i found out myself so i just merge
these two files
together that's what's happening here so
here i do the merge
here i look at exceptions for the merge
something you always have to do
so what i usually do is i say i i
i put an indicator for the merge and
then you can say okay if i if the
indicator
is not equal to both so if if there's a
record in one of the two data sets that
didn't match then output it
in this case it didn't output anything
so everything was was matched
for example i found out that there's a
space behind one of the one of the
reasons
regions here so that's the usual stuff
um so yeah there's a lot of data
manipulation here to get from this data
frame uh
containing values and latitude longitude
values to a list
of coordinate values that is the inputs
that that
volume needs and then just calling
volume with those parameters
and this is what comes out so i'll just
put it on a higher frame rate here to
make it a little bit faster if you then
play it it will
it will simply plot this data on an
animated map
and you can see very well how this
disease spread and behaved
over the country so now the first wave
is gone
first big wave there comes the second
one
uh and then it really gets bad and yeah
i'm sorry to say that this is the
current situation projected one week
ahead you can see it goes
ahead to october 15 but
things are not looking good in the
netherlands so that's that's basically
what you can see from here
but if you do this in more detail and
i've done one from municipalities as
well which has much more detail
but then for some of the municipalities
too little data for a good fit
you can see in in much detail how this
uh how this
progresses uh uh over the map
right so i guess yeah well it's exactly
eleven o'clock so that's uh that's good
timing yeah i'll be honest i've been
watching the clock and
try to end at this time but because yeah
by now you can probably uh
gather that i can talk about this for uh
for days so yeah if you
if you go to the gitlab link that you
see there's
there's an extensive readme here so that
that tells you how to pick this stuff up
and get going for yourself
um yeah so i would say um go ahead have
fun i'll be available for the next
hour as well for questions yeah
there you go yeah so thanks uh damian
this is a perfect
timing and i was supposed to be taking
questions but uh
you have been taking the questions
yourself right so i do have a question
how do you do this
you're presenting and doing code at the
same time as taking questions
uh yeah actually you can't because it's
uh no
nobody can multitask properly but it's a
matter of
because i wrote all the code myself so i
know exactly what's there
so that that helps a lot um and i've
been doing this for
i've been working at this for for the
last half year or six months or
something
so the story comes easily and then
i've got time available in my head to uh
to look at the questions as well and i'm
using two screens so that's uh
that also helps okay i didn't send any
video but most of the time i was looking
sideways and i've got the
all my code on the second screen running
inside the vm
linux vm to to separate it out from all
my other work
uh so i'm just presenting that content
and i've i've got you on my laptop
screen
so yeah yeah perfect yeah it's great
that you've been taking uh
questions already and yeah let's see
whether we can
continue the discussion a bit i do have
two
or some questions myself which i didn't
post already so i can
still ask the question at the end um so
i was wondering have you also been
looking into the
asian-based models or the network models
are you familiar with those
uh yeah i looked into those but then i
thought
and and obviously how this would compare
to those models
because i mean this is not a replacement
for that it's
it's an addition i would say so it would
uh
it would prompt you to to look at
certain uh
places or certain age groups or whatever
in more detail in your other models
so it doesn't replace them i think it's
in addition to that
and uh and i did i did look into those
uh
to get to know how this stuff is
typically done and then i decided to try
and do it in another way and see what
comes out
yeah yeah yeah so interesting thing we
in one of our meetups we had um
also a guest speaker from london from
the ai for good project and they were
mainly focusing on those projects and
i've been
both also a little bit and trying to
build such a network model myself
but i think it's a little bit of more
simulation based methods right so
it is really interesting if you want to
model specific interventions
but it's kind of more inside the
simulation right and i guess
what you are doing is more modeling the
real data that's out there
yeah exactly that's that's what it is
and and i found out that there
uh there uh for such a simulation like
or a sur model to work correctly
i have to put in so many assumptions uh
that was thinking yeah i i can i can
make up all these assumptions because
yeah you really need to be an
epidemiologist
to do that correctly and that's not what
i am so i decided to
to yeah to turn it around and use as
little data and as little
uh assumptions as i could to see if you
could already
find out something by doing that and
yeah i i think i did
yeah yeah yeah you certainly did and we
saw a lot of great
codes so thank you thanks very much for
the talk
and for all that and these you can
continue looking into the goat and
damien will be available in the discord
channel so we can
continue the discussion there and also
afterwards we have the lunch break and
we hope to see you back for the
interview with corrine
we are very much looking forward to it
just to
shortly repeat she's the founder of
tomtom and the
codem coding school and they have a
pretty
unique approach in learning students
how to program so please start looking
into the code
join the discussion and we'll see you
for the interview with corrine after the
break
you